female genital mutilation has altered  the lives of over 140 million women  worldwide although illegal in most  countries FGM is still performed in 28  African countries and also in the Middle  East and Asia in Somalia alone it  affects 98% of women despite the fact  that it is illegal in the EU some 500  thousand women across Europe have been  subjected to FGM in 2013 the EU unveiled  a new strategy to end the practice the  procedure varies that can involve  removal of the clitoris or the partial  sealing of the labia is often performed  in unhygienic conditions and poses a  grave threat to the woman's health  the European Union is committed to  working collectively to eradicate female  genital mutilation  [Music]  the sick for February marks the  International Day of zero tolerance for  female genital mutilation it's a day to  raise awareness about a human rights  violation that could be ended in one  generation according to the UN  [Music]